hello and thank you claudia
good morning everyone i am quite
fortunate today
to be your guide as we talk to
dr bob johansen who is who's also a good
friend of mine
we've known each other for well over 20
years and i'd like to welcome him today
to the
camp to the campus of stanford
university and
thank him for taking the time to talk to
us this morning
thanks mark great to be with you and
exciting to have a conversation about
the future
yeah well we're going to talk about your
latest book
leaders make the future and the 10
leadership skills you've identified that
are
is you believe critical to
to leaders succeeding in the future but
we're also going to talk a little bit
about the process of futuring because
people may not know exactly what that
means or what that entails
and then i hope we'll conclude our hour
together here by
having you tell us a little bit about
what you see for the future what
uh what the road ahead looks like so
let's start with uh
claudia did a wonderful job of
introducing us but i know there are
really interesting nuggets in your
background so what let's talk a little
bit about how you
came to the process of being a futurist
and um and what's made you interested in
that field and
and how did you get to where you are
today
good well it's a long and winding path
but it started
when i was in divinity school looking at
world religions and trying to think
about religion and values in the future
and i was lucky to be a research
assistant on a conference on religion in
the future
and i literally got to carry the bags of
the world's leading futurists i
i remember running to the helicopter to
get the bags of herman khan who is the
father of modern scenario planning and
had just written
a book then called the prospects for the
year 2000 and this was of course
1968 i was going to say you have to you
have to mention the year don't you
you have to mention the area the dark
ages
yeah so that's where it started um i i
learned about institute for the future
uh when i was in divinity school
and remember i have a vivid memory of
seeing the announcement
on the desk of my professor
and saying wow i'd love to be there
someday
and then you know roughly five seven
years later
uh after i'd done a phd at northwestern
um
i got a chance to go to the first
conference
that introduced the arpanet the
predecessor of the internet and i was on
a panel talking about some work i had
done as a phd
student and on the panel was
someone from institute for the future
and they had the first grant
to study what we currently call today
social media
although recall this is 1972
social media to connect the only people
who could use the arpanet in those days
defense contractors and scientists so
that was my
beginning and my path to silicon valley
before it was called that
yeah well before it was called that
that's a so so really your
career started at about the same time as
the internet
um well roughly you know the internet
started roughly 1968 and it was clear
classified
well just in his descent the part he
started was the public
part of it and he did do a lot to
broaden the access to it
because the original arpanet was focused
on
only defense contractors and only uh
data communications so actually the kind
of things we do now with the internet
we're not at
all right what it was intended to do
yeah
tell us a little bit about institute for
the future this organization that
i would say you are part of from almost
the very beginning but continue to be
part of today what do they where are
they located what do they do
and importantly how do they do their
work yeah so
institute for the future is an
independent non-profit uh think tank
it's
located almost walking distance from
where we are today at stanford
in downtown palo alto we're
looking ten years ahead and as best i
can tell we're the only futures group
that ever outlived its forecast
so we've we've been doing this for some
40 plus years now
we've usually been right 60 to 80
percent of our forecasted futures have
actually happened
but what we like to say is we're not
predicting the future we're
provoking insight um so for us
uh you know forecast isn't so much
whether you're whether the events you
forecast actually happened
it's more do the events you forecast
provoke useful
insight and lead the better decisions in
in the present and
and that's where we focus now so you
mentioned the fact that you think you
get it about
60 percent right and that
as a batting average i suppose that
would be terrific but
as uh as a betting man you'd think well
gosh if someone who studies the future
they would get it right
more than that uh is what what's useful
about getting something
60 right well first of all i said sixty
to eighty percent right oh i forgot
depending on your definition of happened
uh which is often
not uh obvious when we started when the
institute started
there was a focus on event prediction
and if you're doing that kind of
forecasting that actually is more
predictive
we don't do that anymore we focus now on
future forces
so for us a forecast is a plausible
internally consistent provocative view
of what we think will happen and the
purpose of it is to
to provoke insight and lead to better
decisions in the per
in the presence so that's really the way
we get evaluated by our clients not
not did the forecast future happen but
did
the forecasted future lead to a better
decision see i thought in a way
your your job would be easy because all
you'd have to do is come in the morning
decide what the lottery numbers are for
tomorrow go buy a ticket and be a
millionaire and be done with this thing
but it
looks like there's more to it uh well
well actually the value in it
might be something beyond that so again
just so we understand
could you explain the difference between
predicting the future
and forecasting the future and why would
companies be interested
in either well predicting predicting
is saying something will happen um
and there are differences in how that
word is interpreted even in the
english language but we actually don't
allow the word prediction
to be used at the institute what we say
is nobody can predict the future
if you think if someone tells you they
can predict the future you shouldn't
believe them
especially if they're from california
but
what you can do what you can do is
is a forecast this plausible internally
consistent provocative view of what
might happen and
just to use one example from the company
where you and i met procter
gamble when when we did a forecast and i
remember you in the room when we
presented this
uh we did a forecast on in the early
days of biotech so this would have been
um well roughly roughly 2000 early 2000s
and the forecast was that biotech
would have a profound effect on procter
gamble that was the foresight
we were presenting to the ceo in the top
12 people
and the ceo looked around the room and
said wait none of us have any background
in biotech
what do we do so the insight was the top
leaders needed to learn
something about biotech the action was
a biotech reverse mentoring program
which png then
implemented and all 12 of the leaders of
pmg
met at least once a month for a year to
learn not how to be biotech scientists
but enough
about biotech to make good business
decisions and now if you look at png
products
many of them particularly in hair care
and in detergents
many of them are deeply influenced by
biotech so that's an example of where
the foresight led to an insight that led
to an action
i see well one of the issues that's on
at least it's it's topical it's in the
news has to do with global warming and
the impact of global warming
it seems as though some people are
making predictions maybe our friend al
gore was making predictions about
what cities would flood what cities
wouldn't flood but but how would
how would futuring in this the tools you
bring to that process
help people think about the impact of
global warming or the future of our
earth
in a warming environment yeah um that's
an interesting topic we started studying
global climate disruption in 1977
so as far as i know we did the first
study
on global climate disruption and
obviously it's taken a long time to get
people's attention i think the
value of it in indicate in a case like
that
is to try to get people to think beyond
their normal planning horizon
we we think 10 years is a sweet spot
it's far enough out
that you get beyond people's normal
horizons but is close enough then to be
realistic
with global climate disruption that's
not far enough
you actually have to think further out
and there's great debates depending on
which models you believe
but over that period of time from 1977
to the present
and again we're not environmental
advocates we're not
advocates of any particular future we're
advocates of the value
of thinking long term in the trust that
you'll have insight that will lead to
better decisions in the present
well with regard regard to that you have
to think long term
to see the importance and now there's
pretty much
consensus among the serious scientists
that something
really disturbing is happening there's
the debate is about how long it takes to
get
really bad and the problem is how do you
link that back to the present
right and unfortunately our policy
makers are just not geared
toward that kind of decision well if
you're working with a 10-year horizon
is your tool set does that mean it
really can't be helpful then in thinking
about global warming which has
a longer time horizon certainly a longer
time horizon than that
you know i think it still can be helpful
because um
now maybe it could wouldn't have been as
helpful in 1977
but now we're getting that much closer
and the argument is that much more
obvious
and we're actually behind in terms of
getting things started
so the real challenge is how fast
can leaders adapt and unfortunately now
our politicians are having great
difficulty
deciding anything let alone something as
difficult as global climate disruption
our corporations i think are better
prepared and right now you see much more
sophisticated green policies
in our corporate structures than you do
in the us government
structures which is really disturbing
and is unfortunate it didn't have to be
that way at the very least you'd like to
see a balance well let's
let's uh let's shift gears and talk
about your book
um uh your book about leaders make the
future and
some of the thinking you've done about
if you will leadership and the specific
aspects of leadership that will make a
make a difference in the future and i
think the first question i'd ask you is
why did you decide of all the things you
could have focused on for this book
why did you decide on focusing on
leaders what's the
what's the thinking there yeah the
notion here you know i'm not a
leadership development person i'm a
10-year forecaster you know i'm trained
as a social scientist i think about
world religions
uh but i'm not a leadership guy what i
was challenged by what though
was given the forecast for the next
decade
what kinds of leadership skills would it
take to thrive
and i was asked this question a lot and
i indeed asked that question to myself a
lot
the photograph that you're looking at
now is actually from the first edition
which which came out a little more than
three years ago now
and you'll notice the background image
is a real
internet traffic diagram done by a
graduate student at carnegie mellon
chris harrison
and the notion here is that leadership
in the future is going to happen in the
context
of what we call today the internet but
what's becoming the cloud and actually
cloud
serve super computing is a more accurate
term our
colleague mike liebhold uses that term
so leadership in the future
as we shift from today's internet to
tomorrow's cloud leadership is going to
be so
important and there'll be some enduring
leadership skills and i talk about those
in the book
but they'll also be new skills and in
the second edition
where we've actually changed the colors
on the second edition
uh to a a blue color our client
hallmark we work with don hall and
the leaders of hallmark then the color
of the second edition
oceanic blue is actually the
color that hallmark people the most
trusted emotional brand and people
brand in america that hallmark people
think is kind of comforting and engages
people
in this highly uncertain future so our
challenge really is what does it take to
lead
and it's not meant to replace leadership
development
indeed the second edition i did with the
center for creative leadership
and added a new chapter on leadership
development programs
chapter 11 and a new chapter chapter 12
about personal leadership skills and how
you can develop those
when i i was uh i was going to ask you
about your partnership with the center
for creative leadership
are they if you will helping you execute
the vision of training leaders is that
yes is that what the partnership looks
like
yes yeah we we we're we're ten year
forecasters
um and ccl um the president of ccl john
ryan
read the first edition of the book and i
was actually very nervous because i'm
not a leadership development person
and i didn't know what they would think
about me moving into their space
and quite to my surprise and pleasure he
welcomed me
and invited me in to talk to their board
and talk to his leaders and
and then we eventually ended up writing
the second edition together
and we did the foresight they do
this the scaling and the leadership
development
activities on a global scale in a way
that institute for the future never
could because we're we're a think tank
and we're
we're intentionally small yeah now i i
know your publisher is barrack kohler
and they've done a
a very interesting thing they put up a
small assessment tool
on their website and i thought the
listeners today might appreciate
sort of open up another page in your
browser
and go to uh b i t dot l y
forward slash and again this is case
specific capital s capital c
capital p capital d and then lowercase
leaders
l e a d e r s so bitly
slash scpd leaders and you'll see a very
brief
but i think revealing instrument that
allows you to do a little
self-assessment
about your own leadership skills as they
relate to the uh
the the ten facets that bob has
identified here and
i think a more complete version of this
exists elsewhere but this is a great way
for people to start
yes and and we're actually in the
process now of doing a group
version of this that ccl will manage
that you can do in advance of leadership
development programs
um but building some form of polling
into
workshop experiences i think brings the
discussion in the book
uh to life because the these 10 future
leadership skills
i think they're about right i actually
expected
when the book came out a little more
than three years ago i expected
that by now there'd be an obvious 11th
skill or
12th skill that i just missed but
fortunately there's
there's not so the second edition adds a
lot more detail and adds more tools to
do your own self-assessments
but i think these 10 future leadership
skills are about right
in terms of what we need to thrive in
this next decade
well i know one of the one of the frames
you use to build
your your model of what what makes what
will make leaders successful in the
future
is a concept called vuca and i wanted
you to talk a little bit about what
vuca means where where where the term
came from
and then how you think about it in the
context of of leadership
yeah um the the term vuca
is an acronym that stands for volatile
uncertain
complex and ambiguous and as best i can
tell it was coined at the army
war college the graduate school for
future generals in carlisle pennsylvania
i am not a military guy but i happened
to be there
the week before 9 11 and i was part of a
group of business leaders and
i gave them some feedback that perhaps
they should
work with business leaders not just
briefing
us but also engaging with us and
figuring out what they could learn from
us and we could learn from them
well the week after 9 11 the
army war college which i had learned
when i was there is often viewed as the
slowest moving
the least innovative and the most
hierarchical of all the military
graduate schools the army war college
started referring to itself the week
after 9 11 as
vuca university and i thought
wow that's interesting so i volunteered
and i've now been back
15 times or so since 9 11 maybe a little
more
working with different business schools
and working with different businesses
to bring top executives there to immerse
them in the vuca world
and talk about leadership and talk about
strategy and we've actually flipped this
around now and in the book in
leaders make the future we talk about
how volatility yields to vision
so in a vuca world vision gets rewarded
disproportionately
uncertainty yields to understanding it's
usually market understanding but it
could be
other understanding complexity yields to
clarity and here
the ugly truth of the vuca world this
clarity gets rewarded
even if it's wrong even if it's wrong
even if it's wrong because people are so
confused
so they go for things that are way too
simplistic so the challenge for leaders
is how to be
simple but not simply well take take
that concept how does
complexity you'll yield to clarity
or or lead to clarity i mean what's that
process like
it yields in in the sense it doesn't
necessarily lead
it yields to clarity so in other words
it clarity's
always been important for leaders but
it's never been so
hard yeah right as in the world because
there isn't clarity in many of the areas
where leaders have to work you know what
we used to call the 80 20 rule remember
that
no it's more like 60 40 maybe right now
or maybe worse
where you have to engage with the
uncertainty
but you still have to decide right and
that's the balance and that
you have to deal with the complexity but
the goal is clarity
that's right and so so what the vuca
world has taught us and what what
extreme warfare situations have taught
us is what wins
in the booth world is great clarity
where you're going
but great flexibility how you get there
so in the army this is called
commander's intent right now i don't
recommend using that in business or in
non-profit world
i like clarity better but it basically
means
leaders have to be very clear where
they're going but they also have to be
very flexible how they get there and
you know one of the startling things
i've learned is you know in
in our military in the us now we have 22
year olds
controlling nuclear weapons and i'm
completely comfortable with that
can you say that again because i'm not
sure
we have 22 year olds controlling nuclear
weapons
and i'm comfortable with that because
they make such sophisticated use of
gaming
in particular and we could come back and
talk about this under immersive learning
ability but
the only way to learn how to thrive in
the vuca world is to game it
uh and if you go to the army's website
now you'll see a state-of-the-art video
game
if you join the army you play games your
entire career
and they so seriously game it and
the games are about developing that
clarity in the face of all that
uncertainty
and it's the last uh letter um the
switch that
i think so profound from ambiguity to
agility
so so basically the best leaders have to
be
athletic in a way that we've never had
to be before we have to be agile
and the only way to be agile is to
practice
and to learn in lower risk environments
well if if we could dig into some of
these skills now i i think they provide
fascinating insight as to at least what
your research and what you're thinking
is is all about the first one i want to
talk about
uh is one that's near and dear to my
heart called the maker instinct
now now why is that so important and
and as you're thinking about counseling
businesses which you do
um i mean businesses make things today
so how is this
a very revolutionary idea um well first
of all
the icons that you see here these were
designed by
an artist uh anthony weeks who i've
worked with for many years and
and is also a graduate of stanford and
documentary filmmaking so he's both an
artist and
a documentary filmmaker and we tried to
do uh like zen
like emotionally laden images for each
future leadership skill but the maker
instinct is not new
um we've always had it it's that inner
urge to create that inner urge to grow
things what's new what's new
is we now have not just solo makers
but communities of makers and we have
the ability to amplify
the maker instinct and not only that the
maker instinct isn't just to build stuff
it's to give meaning to people
because if you feel like you're involved
in the making
if you feel like things are personalized
to you much more attached to it you get
much more attachment and much more sense
of meaning so
around here you know we have hackathons
almost every weekend now in silicon
valley
makers are everywhere we've got three
tech shops in the bay area
which are places where you can go just
like you join a gymnasium
or if you go to tech shop you get state
state-of-the-art tools you pay a monthly
fee and
you're part of a community of makers
chris anderson
talks about the maker instinct yeah he
just recently left
wired yeah now taking up the reins of
diy drones which is a
whole other story about how we think
drones are going to take over but he
tells a very compelling story about
about how it's the next revolution maker
makers will will drive the next
revolution because
no longer will we mass produce things
we'll more or less make them ourselves
yeah i think that's that's right
although i i don't think that's an
either or i think what's going to happen
is you're going to see
a lot more maker instinct yes but it's
going to be
connected to this kind of global task
rooting
global matter routing internet of things
kind of phenomenon
that will play out in the cloud so there
will be both
that ability to do mass production and a
lot of that's going to happen in the
cloud
and localized maker personalized but
it's not going to be isolated
you know that's that's what's new it's
the communities of makers
and the maker affair here locally and
make magazine
uh dale doherty the founder of that to
me that's
that that's kind of the father of the
the current maker movement is
is dale dougherty and make magazine and
the maker faire are kind of the
amplification
and places like tech shop are bringing
it forward and then people like chris
anderson are kind of broadening the
message
yeah now i think related to that is this
concept of rapid prototyping yeah
and we practice that here at stanford
it's an integral part of
of how we teach design thinking and and
it's i think some of its benefits are
obvious but when you're sitting in front
of a ceo
yeah you know like let's pick bob
mcdonald at uh the procter gamble
company
how are you convincing them that ceo to
be a rapid prototyper
why is what's the value in it for for
someone like that
yeah well in a vuca world um you can't
get there
by linear planning you have to prototype
your way there and the
in the chapter on rapid prototyping i
talk about ido
and the link to the d school here and
you know the line that's often used in
that context
is the you want to you want to fail
early you want to fail off and you want
to fail cheaply
and that's what you have to do in the
vuca world to figure out how to
how to win so you want low risk ways
of innovating very quickly and
and that's a different mentality so but
i think ceos are starting to get that
now when they realize the future is so
much less predictable than
we used to think it was and you have to
engage more widely and the good news is
you've got all these resources not just
internally
but externally that can help you
innovate so it may take the form of
making
small but quick bets yeah and and
and finding your way to where you want
to go
and and do that in an iterative process
yeah it's like
cycling through things yeah okay i i see
that
let's this is one of my favorite
concepts i know we've talked about this
in the past
this concept of dilemma flipping and i
thought if you could if you could start
off by
first of all explaining what your
definition is of a dilemma
how what what defines a dilemma and then
how you go about the process of turning
a dilemma which most people would
consider to be
a negative into a real positive yeah
well
a dilemma is a problem you can't solve a
problem that won't go away
but a problem where you have to win
anyway so the challenge is
for a problem solver and what's an
example of a dilemma um the classic
example
well uh you want to stay in the png
world the example i often use
is i ask is walmart is walmart a
competitor and they say
yes because they have all these private
label brands well is walmart a customer
yes they're our largest customer
that's a dilemma for png and for many of
the world's largest companies
walmart is a dilemma because you
it's not either a customer or a
competitor it's both
yeah and yet you have to figure out how
to win anyway so that's an example of a
problem you can't solve but you've got
to
be able to win engage with it and win so
i like to think of this as um
it's an akito move the martial artiquito
the martial art akito
takes attacks it's never offensive but
it takes attacks
and brings in the energy of the attack
and then channels that energy back
that's the art of leadership
in the vuca world is how do you take
that energy that's all around us
and re-channel that energy in a more
constructive direction
so back to your example of how you deal
with a large customer and a large
competitor at the same time
what is the what is the dilemma what are
some dilemma flipping
uh uh behaviors that you've
evidenced in that kind of situation well
for example with
with walmart and its suppliers the
beginning of this
um which actually started with p g and
walmart was the sharing of inventory
information
which which said well gee if we if we
look at
inventories more directly and more
quickly
and we give each other transparency that
can help us make better decisions and
that led to a concept
which is now very common in the retail
world joint
value creation where you you don't just
think about
winning and yourself you think about how
can you win together
so that's an example of dilemma flipping
where you instead of trying to
to you know just force your suppliers to
reduce their prices so you can make more
money
you you go in and you say okay how can
we do this how can we think together
within the constraints of the law of
course how can we think together
to come up with creative models for
flipping
what we see is a dilemma into an
opportunity
one of the interesting aspects of the of
the
joint value of creation is in
understanding inventory levels
is that one of the largest sellers at
procter gamble
is a brand called tide and
they have gotten to the point where
walmart turns tide
well over 100 times a year which means
they're selling out their inventory
two to two and a half times a week uh as
it moves through their store because
it's literally just in time delivery
it shortens the the cycle between when
it's produced and and when it's sold
and and the irony of the whole thing is
they're still working under something
like
210 net 19 terms so they have 19 days to
pay
for the product that they sold in two
days
and there's there's a and frankly that's
that's fine with both
procter gamble and walmart but there's a
way of taking that classic dilemma and
turning it into
into a real positive it is but i think
we're related to this and actually i i
included some of this in in my own
dissertation work this concept
of constructive depolarization where uh
clearly we live in a world where
opinions matter
and people have differing opinions all
the time
uh just look at any almost any cable
news show and uh
and oftentimes we find that this
polarization of people's behaviors
creates
sort of barriers to not only deciding
how to move forward but even discussing
how to move forward
so talk a little bit about the skill
that leaders need to have
to if you will my clumsy word diffuse
that situation
through a process called constructive
depolarization
yeah the word i would use is calm the
situation you know what what you want to
do is go into
a leader has to go in and calm the
situation but then figure out
what they may have in common that they
could work together
to not necessarily resolve because
that's probably an unrealistic goal
because many
many polar polarized situations are just
so polarized that you're not going to
solve them and you see more of that in
the future definitely
definitely so the vuca world but what we
say
um you know kathy vyond leads our
10-year forecast and her
overall frame on the latest 10-year
forecast is the next decade
will be the most turbulent in any of our
lifetimes
we've never said that before in our 40
plus years of forecasting
so it's going to be even more vuca than
it was before which means it's going to
be loaded with these polarities that
can't be solved but you still have to
make them better anyway and you have to
calm them
and figure out how to engage with them
in the best way that you can
and it's very tricky to do and it
requires a a different mentality than a
than a problem solvers mentality
well we'll talk a little bit about what
specific things leaders can do
to uh to calm a situation
and actually get two sides talking to
each other and maybe i'm
thinking about sequestration when i when
i say this but
but what can we uh what can we learn
from this concept that you've identified
to help deal with um with highly
polarized situations
maybe specifically what are some things
leaders can do to calm the situation
yeah you know and again i'm not an
expert in the presence so i'm going to
say your forecaster
oh i think i think these budget problems
are going to be with us for a while
yeah yeah so i'm looking at it with a
with a futurist lens um
let me take another png example and then
apply it so
in before the web took off um
png was accused by evangelical christian
groups of having a logo
that was the symbol of the devil and it
actually started to affect sales
so p g then came back and their lawyers
for png said we will sue
anyone who says that our symbol is the
symbol of the devil because that's not
true
it turned out by bringing the lawyers
seems very polarizing yeah very cool
by bringing the lawyers in that made
that made the situation worse um
and and it spread the rumor even faster
so then
a very clever head of communications
charlotte otto
uh went to the conservative christian
employees at p
g who were twice born christians like
the people who had started the rumor
and they said what do we do and they
decided well let's go to the place where
that we think the rumors started which
was a conservative seminary in kentucky
and there's actually a particular dean
i've gone back and interviewed the
people there's a particular dean and
they found the dean
and they went there and they said you
know we're here from procter gamble and
we're twice boring christians just like
you um and
we um want to just explain that png is
actually
a very good company that supports us and
this isn't a
symbol for the devil and and of course
you know as we do
that it's not christian to tell a lie
and it turned out that was the bridge to
find out what do they have in common
that could help calm the situation and
the river didn't go away
but it reframed the conversation and
that's what creative leaders have to do
is not
not fight the polarity in the terms that
you're given
but back off and say okay what do we
have in common here's where the future
can come in
come into play if you look 10 years
ahead you're more likely
to identify what you have in common
beyond the polarities of the present
and can more likely engage with that and
i and i think that's a lot of what has
to happen in washington right now
we've got way too much certainty in this
dialogue
and not enough clarity or it's certainly
complexity too
and well you mentioned used an
interesting phrase reframe yeah
um and it seems that in many of the
theme that runs through many of these
issues is a leader's ability
to perhaps not take a problem as it is
presented
yes but find a way to reframe it yes is
that
what exactly exactly and you and the
beginning of reframing
is listening and my favorite way of
thinking about
forecasting is to to say we're listening
for the future so many futurists spend
most of their time
talking and i try to spend a lot of my
time
listening because listening is much more
important than talking
and once you understand and you listen
then you've got
opportunities to reframe and when you do
talk you're more likely to have
have an impact and in this kind of
polarized world
i'm afraid we're going to see more
extremes so again i say
i my background in studying world
religions i talk about this in a
religious context as the threshold of
righteousness
it's one thing to think you're right
about life it's quite another to think
everybody else is wrong
and unfortunately in the vuca world
you're going to see more
religious extremes where you've got
groups and this will be political
extremes too
that think not only are they right but
everybody else is wrong and that's
that's when it gets dangerous so in the
vuca world we're going to have
more of those situations with people on
the wrong side of that righteousness
blade
and leaders are going to have to engage
with those people anyway and figure out
how to have constructive dialogue with
them at the beginning
the beginning is to listen i i want to
change gears a little bit you mentioned
this earlier
uh this concept of bioempathy and and
how
we how leaders will look increasingly to
the systems and models of nature
to help solve problems yes talk a little
bit about that what
would leaders do well the way i would
say it is it will look to the principles
nature to help
engage with dilemmas because in biology
there's many more dilemmas
and and not so many problems actually so
we've got to get beyond the
problem-solver
mindset into a more think of
organizations as ecosystems or as
gardens or as
forests and think of of yourself as a
leader as a
as a nurturer a gardener so
we we have to play a leadership role
in these uh very organic uh one of the
things i always say now with leaders is
get rid of your mechanical metaphors
don't call them pillars
uh call them the the kind of structures
or the flows within your particular
organization
yeah it's it's it try to get rid of the
mechanical language
in the fixed language it's too brittle
for the vuca world
and bring in more organic concepts in
the beginning as a mechanical engineer
i'm a little uncomfortable with that but
that's okay that's okay but but
bioengineering i think is the future
this in engineering doesn't go away
but it's the blending of engineering and
and biology that becomes
that becomes important and if you're
lucky you've got a biology background
or or some form of life sciences
background because the next big economic
driver will be
biology and the global well-being
economy
just like the last big economic driver
was engineering and the first stage of
the digital age
and if you think about that you can
learn by bioempathy in many different
ways you can learn biology from your
kids
you can learn it from your your cat or
your dog
you can learn it from being a wilderness
camper there's lots of ways to learn it
interesting and lots of luck as i call
it a great source of inspiration
i want to talk about one last skill and
this skill is one that when i think
about you
i think this is probably the most
personal statement
uh that you made but it's also could be
a bit confusing
uh particularly coming from silicon
valley and that's the concept of quiet
transparency
yeah uh what do you mean by that what is
quiet transparency
well you know i think what what wins in
the buca world
particularly this now amped up world of
social media
is to do the right thing to be
transparent about it
and then to be quiet about it if you're
a more traditional
leader that's self-promoting where you
do the right thing
you're transparent about it and then
you're self-promoting
you almost always become a big target
and
often that's unfairly because social
media in many cases are not
fair it's a very uh biting sort of a
world
um so the the way to be a great leader
in in the vuca world i think is to be
strong
and yet be humble and and the beginning
of that is that listening
listening ability to to engage so that
and it's kind of a dilemma you want to
be strong
and yet humble and you know that's
not always common around here in silicon
valley
so we kind of we kind of grew up with
arrogance here it's not a better
humility
it's not but it's becoming more so i
think you you see it a lot more
in in the the the kind of pedagogy of
the d school for example
um there there is a built-in humility
and a sensitivity to process yeah
and and you see it in in the kind of
innovation practices of people like bob
sutton and indeed bob sutton you know
he's
he's a strong yet humble kind of guy to
me i would ask
is there a business leader today that
you think best role models this behavior
of quiet transparency
um you know i've got several examples in
the book the one the one that i um
like to refer to as ellen golinski who's
the head of the families and work
institute so
um you you saw her on she's
on this week she's on all the news
programs talking about the yahoo policy
about
you know not working at home but working
in the office more
so she's one of the world's leaders on
work private life and
and she doesn't call it balance she
calls it navigation
um and she's very strong and yet very
humble in terms of how she presents
herself and and that's the kind of
dilemma is how do you
i'm not saying you you should be weak
i'm saying you have to be strong
and yet present yourself with humility
and how does transparency
uh play into this what's well in you
know in the vuca world
as we move especially toward the cloud
you really have no choice but to be
transparent
the only question is are you transparent
voluntarily do other people force the
transparency on you
and if they google it yeah if it's
forced to transparency it's probably not
going to be as accurate as it would be
if you
opened yourself in the first place so it
seems to me transparency is not absolute
but it's also not optional yeah and that
seems to align with your concept of
clarity in the
it does and and just so the one other
point i wanted to make in this regard
the the
is where we're moving toward a world
where where you have to figure out not
just how to win
but how to win in a way that more people
benefit so so i
i'm starting to call this now scalable
reciprocity
and it links to the ultimate leadership
skill which is commons creating
where you try to create an asset that's
not just benefiting you but it's
benefiting others
on a larger scale and as we move toward
the cloud we've got more potential
not only to create things for create
situations where the leader wins but
where many others win too
and that asset is amplified through the
cloud so
so to me scalable reciprocity is uh is
is a really important next step to where
we're going
well i know in your in your book and
i'll remind our listeners that if if
they'd like to
take a short self-assessment they'd go
to the url
bit dot ly forward slash
scpd leaders you get a chance to
do a little self-assessment on your own
which i think can be quite valuable but
you you conclude your book by offering
some concrete suggestions about specific
things that leaders can do
and perhaps first and foremost of those
is this concept you just mentioned
called uh commons creating and and what
could you describe that in more detail
and what does that mean for a leader to
do
that yeah comments grading is basically
creating a shared asset
that benefits more than yourself that
benefits others
um and i think given the challenges of
the vuca world
all of us as leaders have to move into
that territory um
and there's different dimensions of it
that i'm
considering at the moment but it seems
to me
the first one is is recognizing what's
here right away you know what's your
authentic space where you can play
the second is who are the partners that
you need to do something that you want
to do but could never do alone
and that shares the risk ensures the
benefit the third is asking yourself
what do you have in
surplus that you could give away that
could yield even more back in return so
you're basically giving in order to
learn how to
make money in new ways but how to
deliver value in new ways too
and then and then finally you you ask
how can i
amplify whatever i'm doing on a global
scale through the cloud
and that's really the the essence of
commons creating is
is figuring out that ability
to identify your own right away to
partner
to give in a way that you'll learn
and and then to scale so the issue that
every leader i talk to today is
interested in growth
and is interested in scalability those
are the two hot words that i hear from
ceos well if you're interested in growth
and you're interested in scalability
you better be interested in reciprocity
basically giving things away and the
trust you'll get back even more in
return
because transactions is going to become
the low margin business in the future
right and there'll be lots of
transactions and they'll still happen
but that's not where you're going to
make money
if you want to go into high margins and
you want to have a wider impact
you've got to figure out how to engage
and create
responsibility create reciprocity and
create assets that benefit more than
just you
and who's the leader that is practicing
this today as you
think about the times we might also you
know i'm i'm
researching this right now and and i'm
learning a lot more about it
um but one example that that i think is
really intriguing is ted
the the whole ted conferences just
happened last week
in in long beach and that ted ted
conferences were started by richard
werman and the vision was to create
a a the world's most expensive the
world's most elite conference and they
were all in monterey
and richard was fantastically successful
but he tired of it and eventually sold
it to another chris anderson not the one
you mentioned earlier right
and chris anderson did something really
radical he he opened the content he
started publishing the ted talks on
video
and now all of us has seen him and he
did something even more radical which is
create tedx meetings
where almost anybody can do a tedx
meeting now and
you know what the conference is now even
more elite
and even more expensive than it used to
be this is the last year in long beach
it's going to move to vancouver now
so the right of way and frankly even
more popular more than
what yeah yeah but but
basically by opening it and making it a
commons
he made it even more elite uh and and
created more
value so the right way was ideas we're
sharing the partnering was with speakers
who who are not paid anything but
they're they're
engaging in this term and and they go
through you know a lot of work to share
those 18 minutes or those 18 minutes are
really rehearsed
uh and and then there's sponsors and
there's fans because there is a
celebrity culture around that
uh and and then they're they're giving
away
the videos uh and they're giving away
tedx meetings
um and and then now they're asking the
larger question
is how can we amp it up even more
through the cloud so
it seems to me ted is a good example of
a commons creating
for a business purpose it's it's still
effective but it led to something more
valuable
and even yeah at the process exactly
well that
leads to the very last question i have
and that is what's next
well you know you you've you've been
thinking about leaders
and and how they convert that for
presidents so for the future
um i i've got a few problems but i want
to see unaided
where are you going with your thinking
next yeah well
i'm i'm going head on into this scalable
reciprocity space
and i'm doing my next book with a guy
named carl ron
who you know a former head of the
innovation at procter gamble
who's been working on disruptive
innovation models
um and we're we're sort of the clay
christensen yes he's worked with clay
and with others uh
to kind of look at disruptive innovation
but he's more of a practitioner so he's
an insight to action person
i'm more of a foresight to insight
person and we're working together with
several different companies
and abm bev is the specific one we're
working together on
but we're looking at these new models of
scalable reciprocity so it's basically
reciprocity for growth
is the idea and we're looking
more specifically at the potential
for mega scale partnering
so mega scale commons creating
and and this is our our in our goal is
we want to do a change the world book
so i think there's a potential here for
business leaders to make
not only to make money but make the
world a better place and there's new
models for how that might happen
we're also going to publish this not
surprisingly through barrett kohler
because you know barack holler's
kind of motto is changing the world one
book at a time yeah
um and they're the best publisher i've
ever worked with so they're just the
right publisher to do this kind of book
with
final well great uh i think now would be
a good time if claudia have you
collected any questions would you
okay the question i understood what a
dilemma
is but when we talk about dilemma
sleeping
what are the strategies to use it as a
tool
so the strategy for using dilemma
flipping as a tool the beginning
challenge is to identify is it a problem
you can solve
or is it a dilemma in other words a
problem you can't solve
but you got to figure out how to win
anyway and my advice on that one is if
you're in doubt
think of it as a dilemma default the
dilemma that's the rule of thumb
because if it turns out to be a problem
it's easy all you have to do is solve it
then and you just go on
but if you identify something as a
problem and it can't be solved
then you're you're stuck you're stuck
you're stuck and this has happened a lot
in washington
lately where where you've got
politicians that are stuck in problem
solver language
even though they're dealing with
dilemmas you know think healthcare
you know healthcare is not a problem you
can solve healthcare is a
series of dilemmas that you can make
bigger you're better you can make bigger
you can make better
but you can't solve them so don't
promise you know just don't promise that
so that's the beginning then you have to
figure out a way
to listen and understand the dilemma as
deeply as you can and look for that
common ground that joint value creation
opportunity that allows you to flip
flip that dilemma in into an opportunity
and the challenge i think is figuring
out
then what are the the models for
flipping
and usually you have to rapid prototype
those yeah before
reframe reframing or reframing yes
another great pool for doing that too to
think about the problem
from a different perspective that's
right that's right it's it's really
particularly with dilemmas you you don't
want to assume that the frame you're
given
is the frame you want to keep
how do you enhance so
uh read chapter 12.
question you've been asked before so
chapter 12 goes through each of the 10
future leadership skills
and and helps you do a self-diagnosis
and then gives you advice about how you
can improve your skills in
in each one of those areas and i don't
have time to answer that
question comprehensively here but that's
basically the challenge that i was
tackling in
in chapter 12. almost like anything i
mentioned the first step is awareness
i i think that is a big first step is
just figuring out
that it you know it's not that
leadership is completely different as
you look toward the future there's a lot
of enduring leadership skills and i do
talk about those in the book
and these 10 future leadership skills
some of them are completely new
but most of them have some roots in the
past like clarity
but it's just they're harder now and
they're different now than they they've
ever been
ever been in the past
you